this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you bad
[__] it's Thursday the 15th of
December the joint is brought to you by
the freeze pipe tremendous the bong of
your holiday dreams is finally [__]
here freeze pipe the piece that gives
you a cold call free rip every time just
freeze it pack it and light that
[__] the Hot Smoke passes
through the Frozen part cooling it down
and you blow out a nice cool little
smoke listen I've had a thousand bungs
I've been smoking dope for [__] 50
years this is the best apparatus I have
freeze pipe is non-toxic it freezes
faster than water and it stays Frozen
longer it cools down the Smoke by
hundreds of degrees and now the freeze
pipe is even better for 20 23 they
updated their bong so you have
independent six independent freezing
calls for even better airflow and much
easier cleaning experience they're easy
to clean they're easy to handle and they
give you a hit that you [__] if you
heard from the one I drew lately no he
lost both eyes your Uncle Joey is taking
care of you for Christmas do me a favor
go to thefreeze pipe.com press and code
Joey and I'm Gonna Save you 10 but look
at those bonds listen the bubbler is the
cutest thing you'll ever see in your
life that pipe will [__] destroy you
and the new bong forget about it that's
the freeze pipe
t-h-e.com pressing code Joey and I'm
Gonna Get You 10 off for the holiday
season that's how I roll the joint is
also brought to you by when it comes to
CBD these guys have done more for me
than any other CBD company that's
cbdlion.com listen go to CBD line and
read the third party lab results and
then get back to me see what the [__]
who's gonna give you numbers like that
nobody whether it's the gummies the
Delta eight gummies which right now
they're giving you 20 off on those I
don't know why you're sitting there I'd
be [__] stoned out of my head of you
[__] they got back balls they
got the CBD cream they got pink [__]
that'll change your [__] life listen
they got the tape go to cbdline.com
pressing code Joey and get 20 off
they're gonna hook you up all right
let's get this party started it's
[__] Thursday
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
Joy
[Music]
look who it is you bad [__]
it's your Uncle Joey on Thursday the
15th of [__] December it's a
half way for it's over you got nine more
shoplifting days you got 10 days to
Christmas you got about 15 16 days till
the year is over and that's it
[__] I am excited
2023 is going to be my [__] breakout
year I've been sitting on my hands for
[__] two years
now I gotta change stuff around [__]
like that but no I'm not I'm not
planning on nothing I got the book
coming out I got no movies I got nothing
I just got my family I got Mike I got
Lee and I got my friends Everything Is
Beautiful uh great [__] week this
week you know
not really great I had to go to a
[__] wake nah whenever you gotta go
to a wake it's not really a great week
you know you got one Saturday yeah you
know this is Wake season in Jersey yo
watch The Sopranos they were wakes every
[__] episode yeah you can't go to all
of them you could just you have to like
pick up wake like okay that one's in
[__] an hour away they're not gonna
see me I'll send flowers every week
somebody's dying somebody's sister and
I'm the type of guy listen if it's
immediate family I'll go
if I grew up with you some if I know you
but I'm not going to go to your sister's
cousin I can't I'm not even supposed to
listen I get creeped out in those
[__] places that's what I was talking
about that's why I got to tell you about
this yesterday because I usually go to
awake
I send flowers first and then I go to
the wake and I sit in the back and I
watch the family and I watch all the
stuff they put up like the pictures of
the family and
yeah they have videos I sit there I
don't want to be I'm not there to
[__] rough runny feathers I'm just
there to observe and to be supportive
you know so
I gave it about you know you give it a
couple minutes and then you go up you
say a prayer you
dog saying a prayer by the body used to
creep me the [__] out I would just close
my eyes and and whatever and then you go
up you shake the family's hand you talk
to them you sit with them and they got a
lot of people to talk to and you uh
don't make a big scene and you [__]
slip out of that you know if they're
immediate family you gotta hang till the
end and
and it's great because like I forgot
what it was to go to a [__] wake you
know since I've been back yet
I went to my sister-in-law's way one of
my best buddies died I didn't make it to
that wake
it was in the heart of covet I didn't
want to mix formaldehyde with [__]
Covenant I don't know if you guys even
know what I'm gonna get into but
yesterday was different because he was
he's a dear friend of mine his mother
passed
and he's been nothing nothing of
supportive of me since I moved back here
he's great with my daughter he taught my
daughter how to play baseball and he
goes to a [__] games and he shuts his
mouth and you know he's just a great guy
so when I found out his mom died his mom
came to my the Mercy's [__] Community
like he went down there picked her up
and brought her to the party you know
and
so I was like you know let me go up
there I just made a day of it I worked
out I did what I had to do around here
and then I shot up there
the Wake was in North Bergen and my
buddy venary's Funeral Parlor and I uh
stopped at my favorite restaurant Rudy's
first I had a meeting up there first so
I I was gonna go from the meeting
straight to the [__] wake at three
o'clock the Wake started at three I was
gonna walk on at 301 and be in the car
by four that was the plan because it's
an hour drive back with traffic Route 3
the whole [__] thing so I got to this
meeting we had a cup of coffee
and uh that was it we talked about what
we had to talk I signed two contracts
they came over from the city I said I'll
meet you halfway in Fort Lee
and uh I got in the car and I had like
maybe it was like 2 15. I probably had
45 minutes to spare I said you know what
let me go to Rudy's I walk in the
[__] Rudy's it's back
because it's the on Croatia was playing
Argentina and the soccer thing I had to
sit in the [__] back there
I got a nice little Rhode Island [__]
clam chowder they make it the best
and I got a half water column that's it
no [__] on trim telling you I'm going
on this [__] superb diet so I finish
up there I see some guys I know on the
way out
of Rudy's and I drive through my
hometown and holy [__]
holy [__] I don't know what the [__]
happened up there because whenever I go
north I don't go through my own town
because of the goddamn traffic I just
the traffic is that you just wanna [__]
L.A traffic listen when I tell you [__]
I like traffic
Hudson County traffic is an all-time
[__] horror show Bergenline
if you go to Edgewater road if you go to
Kennedy Boulevard it's unbearable
so you know it takes me [__] I mean I
could get from Rudy's to veneeries
in 12 [__] minutes 10 minutes you
know took me 30 [__] minutes if I
wasn't behind a bus if I wasn't behind a
double parked car a [__] Puerto Rican
bus you got those Spanish buses on Union
City where they [__] stop for a
dollar the buses too but the immigrants
take those for a dollar and get a that
[__] stops everywhere they don't
have bus stops so they could just stop
anywhere you got to pay attention I
could I went down Bergenline for about
[__] 10 minutes and then I had a
hooker right and get the [__] off
Berglund I got enough this is this is
enough to make you want to [__] crash
the car then I got on Kennedy Boulevard
and that was worse
to a degree I moved around and [__]
if you I'm telling you everybody's
making a left turn and you're behind
them like and now you got to wait for
there's a thousand cars coming the other
way so you ain't getting out of that
[__] left-hand Lane
so I get to the [__] funeral Paul I
parked my car I didn't dress up in a
black suit forget it I'm not putting a
suit on for a long drive that'll that'll
[__] destroy me so I [__] uh
just want like a nice black sweater I
busted out a brand new pair of [__]
Adidas I'm not wearing those things no
more because my feet [__] stink to
High Heavens these Nikes are a lot
better on my feet yesterday my feet
smelled so bad last night I had to spray
Lysol downstairs because I could smell
it I finally go I can't I can't walk
around with dirty feet I went and took a
shower like [__] 9 15. I was like I
can't can't have that I soaked my feet
I went over I walked into that [__]
Funeral Parlor man
now Venere funeral is one of my tightest
friends in the world I love Anthony
Anthony's busy now you know he's got
politics and he's the county
commissioner
I don't see him as much as I do we're
older you know so it's like we talk on
the phone once a week and quite twice a
week and I see him every three months we
go to dinner and
I haven't seen him in like two months
last time I saw him was in El Nito when
I went to dinner with uh Vic and he was
there with a couple of my other friends
I walked right past him
I didn't even know there was three guys
standing and I just walked right past me
he goes Coco I'm like I I didn't even
recognize I mean we're getting old guys
he was talking to the mayor I just
hugged the [__] the man I didn't even
know what to do I just hugged the
[__] man real tight he didn't invite
me to your wedding it's shitty he'd even
no way I love the [__] I love man Sacco
he's a good [__] dude but uh then I
talked to Anthony from and he goes come
see me now I had grown up guys you know
I walked through that Lobby and it's
like deja vu
19 [__] 80.
2022 23 and 10 days 15 days
I've been walking into veneers since
1978 since I was 13 years old I've been
walking into an Aries
either for awake or because he was my
friend you know
and while I was talking to Anthony
before I turned around I'm like man
this place has got smaller no I got
bigger like when I was a kid I just was
always in there so I said hello to
Anthony I walked in I saw the family I
saw Eddie and I just sat down I didn't
say nothing to anybody there was maybe
40 people in there I just sat there and
looked around the room I looked at the
pictures I looked at the [__] they had
no video playing they just had the
family I'm looking at and all of a
sudden people started coming in
and it was like one after the other
all the kids that were maybe two years
older than me that I knew well that I
had grown up around
uh my friend Brian to go me walked in
[__] I love that dude I don't know
how many dentists I had in this [__]
house growing up with his brother Mike
and his brother Teddy and it was just
great to see him he came right over sat
next to me started bullshitting I'm like
where the [__] do you live
and then two guys came in there was two
other guys just standing there you know
and I looked at them I didn't recognized
them
and finally the guy goes then you go to
Five Star Basketball Camp with us and
I'm like who the [__] are you when he
goes I play for Snyder blah blah blah
blah I know Greg horenda
we were talking about Five-Star
Basketball Camp but loosened me up and
then at that point Eddie came over you
know I gave him a hug he thanked me for
coming you know his family was busy with
other people because listen awake works
this way this is the way wakes used to
work they used to be a two-day wake the
first day is the family
second day is for friends since covert
hit they've cut wake hours in half if
you've got three hours for a [__]
wait now it's a lot
so the earlier people like the three the
only reason why I went up early was
because [__] uh
I had to be back for wrestling practice
and the traffic you know I just wanted
to get it out of the way I wanted to go
pay my respects and see them
I would have gone at night if it was a
Wednesday night oh [__]
I would have gone at night because
I would have gone to [__] the burger
place in North Bergen there's a place in
North Bergen Hudson burgers I hear
nothing but good things about them they
put a picture of a hamburger some of you
ever see a picture of something like God
damn it was God damn somebody told me
they were used tremendous meat the
girl's name is Vienna Bello so you know
I follow her on Facebook
and I was like [__] it I'll go to the
wake and then stop and get a burger and
Hudson Burgers say Vienna I haven't seen
her in years say hello
but now I had to go in the daytime so
you know I walked up I [__] talked to
a few people
and then people just started coming in
Cameo the fire department
you know it's one of the guys in the
fire department I had grown up with I
came over and gave him a big hug
Cameo when I saw him I gave him the
biggest hug and I go bro tell these
[__] that we were the first
picks of McKinley because we all went to
McKinley down there in that [__]
school across the New York Hotel was me
Cameo the Cortina brothers one's a
doctor and one's a [__] teacher at
Union Hill
and the Beast
Alexia that's what they used to call
them in Spanish that [__] was a
beast in two languages
and the Beast so
I'm talking to all these dudes and
there's a minute while I'm just sitting
there guys and all of a sudden it's like
it's like I smoke the [__] joint like
when you first smoke a joint when you're
a kid and it just you sit there
mummified and then your brain opens up
and you get all these [__] weird
thoughts about playing on stage with Led
Zeppelin you know you got all these when
you were a kid you smoke pot that's what
happened to me yesterday without smoking
pot it's like the [__] valve opened
up and all the memories I had in from
that place just started popping the [__]
up you know when you walk into a funeral
parlor you could smell the flowers
you smell the flowers it's like a mix
from aldehyde flowers but when you go
away from it like I was thinking of a
story in 1993 when I came back Anthony
had a gym downstairs a [__] beautiful
gem pulleys and benches and Olympic
weights you know
I don't know who was using it and he
told me I go can I use it and I was
broke you know I was a starving comic
and I would come all from the city some
nights and just shoot in there like at
seven
and you know my friend reago would pick
me up like at 9 30 to go do comedy
somewhere so I would work out for like
45 minutes and take a bus to Cliffside
the problem was that I would lift
weights next to the room where they did
the embalmings
and the [__] formaldehyde you would
smell it you would smell the
formaldehyde as you were working out so
you're in there
you know breathing doing sit-ups Jumping
Jacks and [__] by the time I was outside
I was all [__] up I don't know if you
[__] have ever smoked a joint
with formaldehyde in it it'll [__] you
up for three [__] days you'll hear
[__] you've never heard before
so I'm sitting there and I'm like
thinking about how many I only did a
lift down there like three times because
after the third time I'm like I can't
take this [__] this formaldehyde gives
you a [__] headache and a half and I
thought about cleaning the bathrooms
there I thought about barking people's
cars there as a kid
I thought about [__] uh you know
cleaning the we used to clean the sink
and the the general manager at the time
was a Pickler about hair
like if there was like a little tiny
hair he'd call you in there come here
look at that do you see that hand I'm
like I don't see nothing guy leave me
the [__] alone he was just complaining
about a little hey I used to have to
open the door for people
put the flowers in the flower car I mean
I did and here's the [__] weird thing
guys that when I was a kid
listen when I [__] saw my dad in a
casket only Cuban people do that [__]
they take a picture
of somebody dead in a [__] casket
that is the creepiest [__] thing in
the world
when I was a young kid I saw those
pictures of my dad in the [__] casket
and I was like
I'm not dealing with that [__] I'm never
dealing with that [__] and then the
Cuban religion has a lot of [__]
spiritual things like spiritual things
where there's one part of religion where
they summon spirits and they drink
[__] rum and the spirit talks to you
in African
I did it a few times they creeped me the
[__] out uh it wasn't for me but I was
young and I wasn't paying the rent so I
had to go for a ride you know what I'm
saying there was no babysitter available
so
uh yeah that was my ride my mom so you
know it wasn't for me and then
I still remember my mother's weight guys
she was in the casket and there was a
couple nights like I'm like
she's my mom I ain't going over there
like I'm not [__] going over
like the night that I came in and heard
zaraida [__] she was doing bumps and
telling how she was gonna take care of
me I was 30 feet away from her guys I
didn't want to be close to that body it
took me like two days to get close to my
mother's body she's your mother and on
top of that I was scared of ghosts and
creepy things I was I'm telling you guys
I've always heard things and saw spirits
and [__] when I was a kid I saw a guy
with a [__] Cape I wasn't High I was
like [__] six in my backyard I told
my mother there's a guy out there flying
around like a bat you know I was
watching too many episodes of the
monsters I don't know what the [__]
happened to me
but I uh you know just [__] didn't
like that world
after my mother died this is when I
really got I knew Anthony like two years
before my mother died but after my
mother died I got to meet you know I got
to help Anthony and he knew my mother
had dinner so he would help me out from
time to time I was in the cie work study
program
a lot of people don't know that [__] A
lot of people don't even know I don't
even think that exists anymore
the CIA work study program you go to
school at 7 30 in the morning and you
basically stay there till 11 30. it's
like five classes gym
cie something else Vie counts with 15
credits
you could get into the CIA work study
program when you're a sophomore year
I got it in the middle of my sophomore
year the balzano's got me a job Pete
political Pete was taking a different
job so political Pete wanted me to take
the job so I could [__] keep the
stealing up because he knew once he'd
quit that they would know how much
plywood and lumber he was taking so he's
like you got to keep it up go I'll give
you some accounts just give me a taste
okay
so I knew all
I knew all these [__]
in fact there was a cemetery across the
street where my mother's buried
you know many times I went up and down
that [__] block and I would never
walk on the cemetery side I would always
grow up walk across the street from the
cemetery and I would make sure I was
looking up I would never even look at
the cemetery that's how much of a [__]
I am when it comes to [__] Spooks and
goblins and all that [__] I still sleep
with a night light on there's got to be
a little light in my [__] room all
these people I lied turning black I put
shields on I don't want to see no
[__] Shields cause if I'm getting
choked I can't see in the middle of
[__] night I dog I was around with
Rick Ramirez that [__] was
breaking into your house and choking and
taking your eyeballs and [__] he ain't
doing that [__] to me dog remember that
company that sponsored me for a while he
send those sleep lens I did it for like
a month and I'm like
I don't know I don't feel uncomfortable
I kept having to pull the [__] Zorro
mask up with the sleep apnea mask so it
wasn't for me
so when I started it when I took the cie
work study program I had to run the
lumber job
when Miranda Lambert fired me I had no
other choice and then I used to see
Anthony there at the cie work study
program because he had other young kids
in the program so I just told them dog
you gotta sign me up so he would sign
you in that you worked you had to work
maybe four days a week that's the
requirement maybe three days part-time
from twelve to five
and uh
I I still remember like telling Anthony
in the beginning listen I don't mind
cleaning bathrooms I don't mind
vacuuming off there's a lot of vacuuming
that a lot of vacuuming offices
scrubbing walls I'll do anything just
don't
you know put me around the bodies and
he's like sure but he probably knew in
the back of his head the evolution of
the funeral business that the more
you're around it you got to get closer
to the [__] body you know the bodies
are there you gotta adjust chairs
so there were nights we were putting our
chairs and stuff the body's already
being laid out
so little by little
he started taking peeks at the body you
know what I'm saying and I would like
catch myself and go look and I would run
the [__] out of there like I can't deal
with this [__] and then finally like one
night he's like hey man we gotta go pick
up a body and we went yeah that I worked
for him what am I going to do we got to
pick the body up at JFK airport because
people from this area moved to Florida
they die and then they come back to
[__] uh
you know when they die they want to be
buried back up here with their loved
ones I don't know how many [__] days
we went to all those airports Newark
Kennedy and he had me Glen Conti on the
roster he probably sharples who's still
there Jimmy labrano he had all of us man
he you know this was like the perfect
[__] job it was part-time he would
let let me work nights sometimes till 8
o'clock at night but that job having
that job
overcome my fear to being around [__]
bodies even when I go to the cemetery I
would go in the back door of the
cemetery like not a door like a Back
Fence because it was a shorter distance
to my mother I would never take the
because I didn't want to be caught the
[__] in there that's how now I walk
through the [__] cemetery and it's
because of Anthony
because of picking up and being around
uh you know dead bodies you know
but the [__] clinker was Michael
Jackson was playing at The Meadowlands
19 [__] 85 the victory tour
Anthony had four tickets he was gracious
enough to take me at that time Anthony
was my you know I was down and out guys
and he would take care of me I slept on
his pool table
you know
he was a great friend he still is a
great friend I'm lucky to [__] have
him but
we were going to [__] Michael Jackson
and we were in a rush to get to the
Meadowlands
and we had to pick up a body in Kennedy
Airport and a hearse and we came back
and uh I ran in first because I had to
get on the phone somebody had paged me I
ran in and the garage door open then
they have rollers and you just one
person could do it really just pull the
body off and the wheels come down
automatically and then well by mistake
when he pulled the Reel down the body
was rolling towards me
and I didn't even know it and when I
turned the Body Hit Me and the guys had
a you know thing on it but I saw like
from the impact that hit me his little
mouth opened up guys I wanted to [__]
die right there
die that don't happen to most people
you know and I was like that's it my
funeral [__] Paula days are coming to
an end but that that right there that's
something that would have [__] killed
me when I was you know three years
before that four years before that so
at that time it was uh
it was it worked but I'm sitting there
daydreaming about all this [__] like I'm
like and people like Hi how are you and
I'm like hold on one second let me
finish my [__] Daydream because it
was tremendous it all you know it's like
a [__] well of information that came
in and I'm like wow
that day oh yeah we went to the Michael
Jackson concert like we own that
[__] The Jacksons were there for
eight nights then there was a break for
two days then Bruce Springsteen was
coming in for nine nights this was uh
yeah July of 84. that's how back we go
you know so it was uh it was great just
to open up my mind to that I hadn't
thought about that
and here's all the [__] hustling and
just being in that place it was one of
the best jobs I ever had it taught me a
lot it taught me detail
that job taught me how to detail people
don't want to come in and that's why
that dude was so picky about the hairs
and [__] people paying for a funeral and
he did guys I've never met anybody I had
a bad experience there as a matter of
fact
I got my little [__] tub of candy and
[__] yeah Canary Funeral Home
North Bergen New Jersey my brother he
gave me a 93 every year he gives
something like when I went up there
yesterday I brought some pens back I
brought some I gave my daughter a pen
this morning to take to school
give this to your teacher just in case
you know I I uh I always use his
calendars for years I would only use
this calendar
his calendar was my comedy calendar but
every funeral I asked him yet he got a
calendar for me he gave me that
but uh
it's it's [__] crazy he gave me a bag
you know when you at the end of the
funeral you have all these Mass cards
and stuff and you put them in a bag with
Vanilli made a Venere funeral home back
and I didn't you know I just he gave me
to me one day and I didn't think about
it then all of a sudden I got a job in
the city and I'm like [__] it now we get
on the train with that little bag and
people look at me and go
like people would get grossed up by me
having a little Funeral Parlor bag it's
at venary funeral Paul but the Highlight
yesterday was I never mentioned this
dude's name to you guys because I don't
want to confuse anybody
when I grew up I grew up with the
balzanos and this is the Highlight
yesterday and uh and it happened as I
was walking out
I went to see Anthony I said goodbye
again big hug I took a picture of one of
his employees I saw my buddy sharples
who I loved daily and I went outside and
once I was outside somebody's like Coco
is that you and I'm like yeah he goes
you don't remember me I go I [__]
remember you
he goes you know man he goes uh I mean
me and this guy were not tight at all as
a matter of fact I know for a fact as a
kid
he was not fond of me he was a straight
up guy you know I forgot to ask him what
he ended up doing
but his father used to work at Randall
Lumber with me he didn't work for Renda
lumba
and this is why you know I won't mention
his name because his father was the dude
who bought coins
he bought coins and rings in
1979 and 80 if you guys check it out for
yourself Google it the price of gold
skyrocketed like 800 an ounce
and all these places started popping up
like little play you know we buy gold
chains he had a little like a little
[__] thing
at the hardware store and I would go in
there every day and I was polite to them
you know for the sake of the story his
name was Mr B
I always told you guys between the ages
of 16 and 19 I had this creepy [__]
other life
once I moved Uptown that creepy downtown
life went away you know when my mother
died when I turned 16 17 all those years
I go Mike Denny and he was doing some
creepy [__] and I couldn't tell my
friends what he was doing he's doing
time now in North Carolina it doesn't
matter and uh we were doing some creepy
[__] and I just had you know I had my my
regular high school friends
but they had to be an 11. I had no
[__] curfew so I would do little uh
side jobs with these other guys you know
they were just teaching me the ropes
and I had my Danny I had this guy Pat
and I had this guy Mr B Mr B was the
most decent on the wall Mr B belonged to
a crime family he never told me that but
I Knew by talking to him and talking to
other people he was very low-key had a
shitty [__] car he would just go in
there every day and buy [__] coins
that was his gig as a mafia dude he just
bought coins he had some money he had he
had a construction company too on the
side
so uh we became friends and he told me
if you ever have coins or anything bring
them by it was perfect because at that
time I was beginning my journey into the
low life isms of uh burglaries and [__]
and I could just bring him [__] he
wouldn't make me do paperwork and he
wouldn't say nothing to me you know he
never judged me never asked
he bought me lunches across the street
there was like a little place on Tully
Avenue he would buy me lunch and he
would buy me like little bagels and [__]
like that oh I know what he would always
buy me ham and egg on a [__] kaiser
roll tremendous
so uh
and then he started giving me little
[__] jobs like cool jobs like some of
them were kind of kinky
but he's the guy that used to make me
sweep the roof
you know like sweep the roof fifteen
dollars just an hour just sleep I'm
[__] 17 years old 15 an hour at that
time I blow you if I was 450 an hour
[__] minimum wage this guy's giving
me fifteen dollars an hour for five
hours
he would make me like if his
Construction Company built the wall I
don't know why if there were Union or
not I don't know if he was just trying
to help me out he was going picking me
up at five I want you to sit by the wall
between six and nine I don't care what
you do bring a friend to sit with you I
need you by that [__] wall and I
would just sit by the [__] wall with
this guy and then they taught me about
like he he was one of the many guys that
would always sell hot [__] like he had
blow dryers and [__] you know bubble
bath he's I mean when he came in with a
case of Mr Bubble one day you guys don't
you remember Mr I bought like [__] 10
of those things I love Mr Bubbles I gave
him away for Christmas presents and [__]
this guy would bring his [__] all the
time to the hardware store but I you
know I got to know him and he told me
once he goes you know my sons aren't
crazy buddy I gotta know they're a
little older they're a little more
strict
and uh
he just helped me out a lot when I was a
kid he was one of my creepy I must have
done a thousand [__] dirty things for
him that nobody knew about but uh you
know we just stopped hanging one day but
when I saw his son he goes he died you
know like how's your daddy because he
passed away but
you know
15 years ago or something goes but
he goes I uh
showed him the uh the longest yard and I
told him that was you
he goes boy he got fat
he goes I bet he was proud of you at the
end he goes you know he gave me his hand
he shook my hand
and that was it that was my [__] wake
I got in the car I saw another buddy of
mine a villa
I saw this guy balls I haven't seen him
since high school that was his name boss
and he had nothing but balls this guy he
was tough [__] and it was just
kind of nice to get out of here and uh
it's a shame it was awake you know
that's what like happened here usually I
go to a wake I'm [__] up for two days
not this time I felt kind of good it was
uh it was her time to go it wasn't a
horrible [__] death you know she was
80 and I felt great about it so
every once in a while you got to go to
your comfort zone I hate [__] weights
I hate them with all my heart and when
he first called me and told me about his
mom dying I can't tell you I didn't cry
a little bit in the car because he's a
sweetheart he's an Irishman his mother
was iron he's bad man all his friends
like from The Gourmet again all those
guys that were there talking all said
the same thing they remembered his
mother going back to his house with his
mother and she would have cookies and
[__] they would play baseball
it's just a different [__] life and
that's what I was talking to Google me
about he goes you know I listened to the
podcast from time to time I listen to
church a lot more because my son was
home
he goes and he would ask me about those
stories and I told him we grew up
in a very [__] special place with a
very special bond I mean he had a bunch
of his childhood friends in there that
was just
tremendous to [__] see anyway enough
with the [__] uh funeral Paul but
remember boy your funeral thanks go to
venary funeral parlor my brother Tommy
you want the cocoa discount you get like
a dollar off maybe he'll give you an
extra flower or some [__] like that and
then I had some [__] excitement
uh uh I wanted to have some excitement
Monday night at practice
guys I love my daughter I'm not father
of the year I've never said I was I
never said I was the man of the year
I make a ton of [__] mistakes and but
I do have one thing going for me it's
not comedy it's not the size of my balls
it's not that I'm funny none of that
[__]
the only thing I have that's always very
good on my side is I've always been very
intuitive
if that's the word to say
I've always looked at things and go you
know what that's not for me because I
tell you what's going to happen this is
going to happen this is going to happen
and I'm gonna I've always been one of
those guys it's not negative thinking I
for years I thought it was negative
thinking it's just a way to think that
you know just it works for me guys
so my wife took this coaching job and uh
again it's her job I never [__]
muscled in I never nothing nothing she
did depicts she does the lineups I don't
even sit on the coaches thing I sit on
the other side and I just cheer for her
and I cheer for the girls
and
right before the season started she goes
I got a call from this girl she wants to
play the father called me okay
and we get down there and I see the guy
and I see how he's talking to my wife
and I see how he's acting
and right away I made a [__] decision
like oh this guy's gonna be a problem
it doesn't take a genius
doesn't take a [__] genius to know
this guy's going to be a problem
you know again when I go watch my
daughter do whatever
I've never I don't give a twenty dollars
to hit a home run I don't you know none
of that [__]
I won
I want her to play the game I want her
to laugh because that's all you want
from your kids and Mike when your son
gets old and he's playing soccer or
stickball whatever the [__] they decide
to choose and he strikes out it doesn't
[__] matter at the it really doesn't
matter at the end of the [__] problem
nobody's gonna remember oh you strip
move it
but you know in the in the sports you
know in the sports world
I've oh I read that Pistol Pete Maravich
book
and I [__] hate it that's one of my
favorite books but I [__] hate it I
hated how is Dad treated him always did
[__] uh you know just mate used to
make him sleep outside [__] beat him
and [__] if he I just and when I came
here I started going to Luke's games
Jimmy florentine's son
and I didn't see a lot of it but I saw
it from time to time you know and that's
okay
when my wife started when we started
playing softball I heard it the first
year but then it disappeared the chitta
chatter the challenging the coaches the
[__] why the stadium have lights why
don't we have hot dogs why don't we have
a [__] why don't we have a flag you
know there was always complaints from
parents I do it's [__] baseball I
grew up in North Bergen you know what
our [__] Fields look like we planted
shits in park the butcher was up there
that [__] would chase you with a
butcher knife that's why they call him
the Butcher and a dog okay when we were
playing baseball so when I see grass
four [__] bases dirt you got me
you're good okay
this year with basketball [__]
everything I mean she picked a great
team that they were all young girls she
picked four other girls from the
softball team so they had that Bond and
you know listen
my daughter all of them they they barely
know the [__] rules okay when I go
there and I'm a basketball dude and it's
paying for the watch okay when you're a
basketball dude it's painful to watch
but I watch it and I understand what's
going on they don't know it I'm just
happy that she's doing it not sitting
upstairs on the [__] computer screen
so
this father every [__] week is
something
and the thing that I saw that I didn't
like right off the bat was that no
matter what was going on with my wife on
the sidelines
this [__] would call his
daughter over and then he would give her
instructions or whatever my wife was
telling her he was [__] giving her
instructions
and that's like backbite and and what's
the purpose of this so she could score
10 points or whatever who's here the
nwba and W what is it WNBA who's here
Holy Cross here who the [__] is here
who's here that [__] nine and ten
years old guys know you're [__] you
know he walks in with a scarf Mr [__]
whatever okay
last Saturday that 3-0
last Saturday going to their fourth game
[__] great game but for some reason
it got a little physical and there was
one ref with a bad [__] leg and he's
got to be 65 [__] years old now
I'm not mad at the ref a dog I had a
glass eye okay in the eighth grade we
had a rough that had one glass high and
if he qualified on you from the [__]
right side we've caught we've you know
challenged him like Doug did you really
[__] see that you don't have a
[__] left eye you got a glass eye how
the [__] did you see that anyway this is
Jersey refereeing this they always got a
[__] dilemma the one guy had like a
little hook and he would blow his
[__] hand with the whistle they
always got some [__] handicap or
something so but they're controlling the
game to the best of their abilities both
of these teams including my daughter
who's a [__] karate [__] Fowler
was karate you know they were each
hitting each other but every time they
would hit this guy's daughter he would
yell rip what the [__] they're hitting
my daughter and meanwhile everybody's
karate chopping up you know any rules
about basketball when somebody jumps to
get a shot you're supposed to jump
straight up once your hand goes down
whether you hit him or not that's a
[__] foul when somebody's dribbling
at you
if you're like this you're fine if they
go to cross over and your hand is there
it's no foul but if you reach for the
ball in high school basketball in New
Jersey that's a file little fingers and
you go but I didn't touch them it
doesn't matter you reached the Reps off
from the other angle you got a glass eye
you [__] up it all [__] works
together
and I'm not saying nothing to the rap
there's two girls in particular that are
really hitting each other the centers
the two centers were battling it out it
wasn't good so anyway
foreign
[Music]
with my friends other parents other dads
this guy's on the other side he won't
shut the [__] up
he won't shut the [__] up why is she
doing this like just saying [__] about
my wife now game one I should have
probably choked him but I didn't I'm a
gentleman I'm a Christian
I go uh you know
I'm not gonna come here I'm not that
type of person guys I don't say [__] at
those games
you know he complained complained
complain file foul file Saturday okay we
left there and then on the way out one
of the moms is like is he saying
something to your wife I go he better
not be and I yelled at my wife brother
Terry and she looked like it was in
[__] problems we could stop this guy
because you gotta nip this [__]
in the butt and that was my problem I
didn't nip him in the bud game one or
two
so this Monday we have practice I'm
sitting on the stage I'm not bothering
nobody I'm sitting one with moms and he
comes in nah what are we doing here uh
we're gonna do a scrimmage and there's
another team there there was one of the
gyms was closed and now we were stuck at
the same gym so we had to go home let's
scrimmage the other game we just played
her on Saturday let's crim it to coaches
like let's do it and we'll stop him and
tell them what they're doing wrong
tremendous my wife comes over and she
goes listen
to the Two Dads she goes listen and the
other dad's a sweetheart he goes over to
his dad and goes listen
today's game we have to learn how to do
assist so your two daughters are not
going to be shooting they're going to be
passing as guards the other guy didn't
say anything the other guy made like a
face whoa she's going to be a
well-rounded player you know right away
I should have got up and said something
I don't say anything guys again holiday
season's coming I don't want no [__]
problems they're playing he's com he's
complaining about the fouls again
where's the fault yeah this was called
continuation from Saturday and then guys
you know
I I just couldn't take it so now there
was a play where the ball went to the
corner and the girls tumbled and he goes
time time time and then the girls
tumbled after he said time this guy
comes flying out of there like hey you
should have stopped after the [__]
playing the coach on the other team goes
whoa relax
relax they're playing it happens and
that's when I just [__] went off I go
guys sit the [__] down you haven't shut
the [__] up since Saturday with those
files what does it matter with you and
sure enough these white privilege
you know the whole [__] thing I'm
like shut the [__] up go let them play
what the [__] is wrong with you enough
and right away he left and they came
back and I talked to my wife and they
went outside my wife's like don't say
another word my wife was mad at me and
they go outside and then they have a
talk and she comes back and her face is
red and I go what happened they go
nothing and then I'm like you don't say
another word and then as the practice
ended she told me what had happened that
she told him she goes you're not a
[__] coach I am and he [__] this
old demeanor change and they told my
wife he was pulling her from the [__]
team so he's gonna [__] on the other
girls because and what really happened
here guys is we've been walking around
Mr White Privilege the other coach shut
him down which was tremendous because
froze and then I told him to shut the
[__] down shut the [__] up you don't
even know he doesn't even know about the
game this guy has never touched the
[__] the basketball in his goddamn
life and I love the daughter she's a
sweet kid she's going to be great player
someday but this guy's one of these guys
that's going to be at every [__]
practice I think my daughter should
start a coach at the camp shut the [__]
up if you want a coach coach until then
shut the [__] up so here's what gets
better the practice ends I'm cool
he's got his little three little [__]
uh coaches out there talking to him now
I told him to go [__] himself and when I
walk out I go is there a problem
and he just looks at me
with that stupid face I walk to the end
of the thing I saw one of my coaches
Eddie Ed he coached mercy so he came on
what happened this [__] guy
because I know that that dude's a pain
in the asses he's walking by he holds
his daughter Tighter and he walks past
me I don't say nothing guys I'm an adult
when I get outside he's outside with his
daughter talking to some other guy in a
[__] Audi
whatever they're talking and I look at
him and I don't say a word though I get
home my wife is like he's texting me he
wants to fight you he wants you to go to
his house right now and all this [__]
and I'm like I'll go to his [__]
house but he just give him the address
let him come here
you know I'm not gonna [__] back down
from some guy I mean I'm a [__] old
man but I don't need this [__] in my
life
but he was texting yeah and then he told
my wife that his daughter's a black belt
and if they follow again she could beat
up old little girls when they're caught
and all this [__] yeah
so I knew Doug I felt really guilty I
hate making a mistake especially
embarrassing my family my wife and my
daughter before I make those kind of
mistakes I grab all the facts I like
when I went off on that stupid coach and
his wife was there too
the [__] coach from the softball you
know he comes to the games and sits in
the other bleachers he's never
apologized to the moms or anything for
doing that to us these are the people
you deal with today it's a shitty
[__] world guys but you know what I
made my [__] point and I thought
about going over there and arguing with
him and not it's like what's the sense
how old do we want now you know what man
this guy is just hurting his [__]
daughter by doing this [__]
I'm happy because my whole point was my
wife's the only woman in that League
I love my wife very much guys
and uh there's one thing about my wife
you call me a speck fat I'm not funny
I'm a criminal you say whatever the [__]
you want about me and I'll giggle it off
for you
you mess with my wife or my daughter
it's not going to be a good day for you
I got nothing to lose anymore it's just
I need to deal with this [__] so I spoke
my peace he told my wife he was pulling
her from the team and getting to throw
it out of the league and all this [__]
and uh my wife made some call yeah and
me not allowed to be at the [__]
games and the whole thing about this is
guys
he got [__] on in public he got [__] on
somebody called him out and what did I
tell you about white privilege they all
do this
nobody's River talk to me like this is
black for me you know no this is the
King of Swing [__] one dime one
phone call 20 [__] Puerto
Ricans how do you want to do this
how do you want to do this
and this is how I live my life I'm just
trying to be a good guy I was telling
Mike that
I get up in the mornings I always try to
make somebody's day I mind my [__]
business I don't give a [__] especially
now the state of mind I've been lately
the last year I don't give a [__] about
half this [__] you guys might think and
people send me stuff do you care what's
going on now guys I tell Mike when he
comes here what's going on the only
thing I [__] read is Yahoo and I read
like one thing until I'm I'm Leo that
still throw Kanye into the [__] bus
every day now he's saying [__] about
Jews family Russian Jews yeah
it's all [__] guys just uh we got
[__] 10 more days to Christmas and
listen
some podcasts along some podcast is
short
as a uh
I love podcasting and I love podcasts
I don't care who what guest is on
I don't care if Jesus is on I don't care
who the [__] is on
the only thing I could do you got me for
40 minutes when I when you do a podcast
you got me for about 40 minutes and then
when I come home that night I can finish
up your podcast if it's three hours four
hours Lex Friedman and all that [__] it
takes me a week to listen to those
[__] things okay
[Music]
when I started doing podcasting we were
doing three hour podcast two hour
podcast on our podcast and you listen to
them
and you're like these podcasts were
great but
they should have ended 30 minutes early
that podcast was great but it should
have ended an hour earlier you know I
just lost the hour of my time listening
to you guys talk about whatever Joe Diaz
improving you know for the 18th [__]
time so
there's days I come out here and I want
to talk to you [__] for an hour
and there's days I got on here and I got
45 minutes and that might be a day I got
30 minutes I don't [__] know and uh
it's all how I feel in fact I'm doing
you [__] a favor it's not that
I don't want to be here it's that
whatever I got to tell you I [__]
told you [__] I'm figuring what
to do out in 2023 I'm gonna talk to Mike
in the next couple weeks we'll probably
take uh the Christmas week off and we'll
make some changes I have been looking
for an office around here I met with a
realtor the other day and she's going to
keep her eyes open I talked to
the guys at the mall over here I went to
the medical building and saw if they had
a closet that maybe we could just shoot
videos in or whatever because I think
the once I get out of the house she'll
be a lot [__] better this was a
two-year experiment I wanted to see what
was going on covid you know before I got
a studio whatever
if I want to drive up north
that's not happening
I don't want to drive up north every day
I don't really don't want to drive much
I just want to keep it around here maybe
a little closer to Mike's house and uh
I'm trying to figure out a way to
[__] guessed and whatnot bear with me
I've been doing this for a long [__]
time and you know I don't enjoy half of
these [__] nightmares but I gotta
Doom I gotta do this [__] to keep you
[__] in check and to keep me in
check because without this I got [__]
nothing
so uh oh and I got good news
you ready [__] laughing gas is in
New York City
but you gotta go to stonerclub.com
put in at the code Uncle Joey one
[__] word and you got a lifetime 10
off
and that's it and they got some other
great weeds they got some great [__]
Edibles over there I'm gonna try to call
ABX today and try to get ABX out in this
[__] it's time to unleash ABX
and this [__]
uh I took six of them the other night I
don't know how I take one and I'm [__]
they still [__] you up I I still tell
people they're the strongest edible out
there I don't you could kill yourself
I wake up [__] up too
I love you [__] 10 days to
Christmas stay black don't forget
Valeria's funeral Paula and that sick
[__] suckers have a great weekend and
I'll see you Monday morning Tip Top
Magoo and now for a worth my
[__] sponsors Jack
all right you [__] Savages I want to
thank you for giving me some love today
and let me give you love and come into
your life and tell you some [__] up
story before we go listen the bong of
your dreams is here freeze pipe I love
this Bond bubbler or the new bong listen
guys for years I talked about Colorado I
would smoke weed out of a bun and put
the [__] snow in it that shit's done
it's 20 23 Uncle Joey throw your [__]
hand away freeze pipe is how we're doing
it now the Hot Smoke passes through the
Frozen part cooling down the smoke as
you inhale it freeze pipe is non-toxic
it freezes faster than water and it
cools the smoke down by hundreds of
degrees the new freeze pipe the bun is
even better they've updated their bung
so they have six independent freezing
calls for even better airflow and it's a
lot easier to clean your uncle Joey's
taking care of this [__] Christmas go
to thefreeze pipe.com pressing code Joey
and save 10 off your first order get
yourself a new bong pipe or bubbler
today that's the freeze pipe.com
t-h-e freezepipe.com and I'm Gonna Get
You ten percent off when you're putting
code Joey you're gonna be smoking like a
[__] Champ in 2023 and the joint is
also brought to you by CBD line I'm sick
and telling you about them I know your
shoulder hurts I know you got shin
splints listen they even have capsules
the [__] CBD to get it to you I mean
listen CBD line has been doing this for
a long time and no wonder while they're
the best so keep me going go to
cbdline.com right now read the third
party lab results and you'll be the
[__] judge nobody matches into that
if you're buying CBD at a gas station
you're [__] done I want to thank CBD
lion I want to thank the freeze pipe I
want to thank manscape and I want to
thank Bluetooth but most importantly I
want to thank you savages for always
having my back stay black I love you and
I'll see you [__] Monday morning
Tip Top magui